immigration is a topic labor leaders
have largely avoided but today kirstama
went Full Throttle on the issue why well
because of the government's record he
believes they failed in the past and
with their new plan they'll fail again
problem just gets worse with every new
gimmick nobody on this side of the house
wants open borders on that side they've
lost control of the body I don't agree
with the home sector very much but when
she says that the Tories are all talk
and no action she's spot on isn't she
claiming I didn't say that I didn't say
that the labor leader did have some
effective lines today but just look at
how Tory MPS reacted to this suggestion
if he was serious about stopping the
boat he'd actually steal our plan on
stopping the boat smash the gangs sort
out the returns and clean up the utter
mess
well in response to all of that the PM
seemed happy to be on populist Tory
territory yes Richardson avoided saying
when the small boats problem would be
sorted but he sees on the opportunity to
create a dividing line between the two
parties on what could be a key election
issue
what we haven't heard is The Honorable
gentleman's plan we know what it is it's
open door immigration
an unlimited Asylum stopping the boats
is not just my priority it is the
people's priority on this matter he
talked about his legal background he's
just another Lefty lawyer standing in
our way
as you can hear a Tory MPS love that
less so this SMP Bob about conservative
rhetoric on immigration
from him or his government taking
inspiration Nigel farage or Enoch Powell
and what a load of nonsense Mr Speaker
what a load of nonsense
Stephen Flynn and a labor MP also raised
the possible consequences of the new
illegal migration bill on victims of
people trafficking
under his proposed new Asylum was a
woman who is sex trafficked to the UK on
a small boat by a criminal gang will not
be afforded protection under our modern
slavery laws can the Prime Minister
therefore clear up
whether sir more father who last year
bravely revealed that he was trafficked
to the UK as a child would have been
removed under this bill
there is nothing compassionate there is
nothing fair about supporting that
system continued continuing and that's
why our new laws are the right way to
deal with this
elsewhere the PM was questioned about
Eurovision ticket touts extradition law
women's rights and when he'll publish
his own tax return
people want transparency in our politics
especially because the prime minister is
the richest prime minister in history Mr
Speaker as I proved you friend I will
publish my tax returns and that will be
done very shortly
the big theme of course though today was
immigration Richardson knows he will be
judged by voters on whether he can stop
the votes I've spoken to senior people
within the home office who admit that is
an almost impossible task but the pm has
made the commitment and seems at least
for now very comfortable defending his
approach